in doing all of my like deep dive in
research on your book and i read the
people magazine article and i was just
reading everything i could to sort of
get a sense of you know where things
were at i can't help it i did get a
little bit obsessed with all the cute
boys that you've
known and dated
well and got engaged too what can i say
oh
it's true
is it true that like johnny depp asked
you to marry him after like
dating for a few weeks
it's worse than that wait what tell me
everything
i was engaged to matthew broderick and
johnny depp
in this same month
[Applause]
yeah it was really a sign that there was
trouble afoot on my part
i mean honestly i just thought it was
god rescuing me from one bad situation
and just lovingly plopping me into a
johnny depp souffle
that's what i thought and you have to
understand johnny depp 1989 johnny depp
so beautiful
yeah so you've never seen a more
beautiful oh
it's you have to read the description in
the book it's
quite it's
it's almost inhuman i will say i'm very
happy that like you look so hot and sexy
you're right wait talk more about that
yeah
[Applause]
and you're doing you know your dance and
you're the most beautiful body and
you're the most beautiful woman and you
were so captivating and i was so in love
with you you know jimmy fallon and i
actually uh re-enacted i know something
in honor of you okay you know you know
how many people have attempted that
it's it's so famous my favorite attempt
really
100
do you know why why because you have joy
even though he's sticking his feet into
your rib cage yes and it feels horrible
and you sold it and it was funny and so
i'm so relieved aren't you so happy yes
forget your seal of approval it's cute
it's such a famous iconic i mean it
literally you did it didn't you enjoy it
i really did jimmy felt like it was best
on his back because i i don't know how
did you guys do that okay you know it's
so scary i did not do it till the day we
shot it
seriously oh no i feel like it must have
been making the producers and patrick
and the director everyone insane because
i refused was too scared i refused and i
basically
just couldn't do it i couldn't make
myself until the day
when all the people were watching and
then i had to do it and you did it and
it's perfect it's perfect
[Applause]
i really do love how you cross your feet
yeah
it's such beautiful form well you know
all those ballet classes as a kid
you know paid off like and i know
there's sort of been history with you
and patrick swayze you know you talk
about it in the book and you discuss
sort of the
you know
disconnect sometimes lack of chemistry
lack of trust trying to kind of figure
it out with each other but
johnny and baby are the ultimate couple
there is so much chemistry yeah i mean
chemistry is very different the body
has a different story than the mind
right so my body and his body
really liked each other uh-huh
there's an energy
where it doesn't make sense in life
but it makes sense between the sheets
has anyone else ever had that
is that am i the only one okay i'm weird
no no no i i well i'm just thinking of
some of the people i mean slept with
that just don't make sense at all
exactly exactly like exactly
but why why exactly all right so
is it true that there is going to be a
dirty dancing sequel
and yes it true
that baby is back at kellerman
we all need this in the world is it true
there will be dancing yeah yes
[Applause]
except oh here's a question
who
do you think would be the choice to be
the next inappropriate match for baby
um
how about shmerry smiles who somebody
who rhymes with mary smiles mary
smiles harry style
yes thank you
yes
you're right harry styles
done
[Music]
you